titanfall 2 has a lot of decent maps but
today we're going to be talking about
the ones that I personally didn't like
and some of the answers I got from the
community on reddit so when I asked
reddit which three maps are the worst
and titanfall 2 these are their top
three the number one answer I kept
getting was crash site most of the
people's complaints were because all you
have to do is get a good position on the
top of the hill and you can snipe anyone
from below another comp another
complaint was that the map was too tight
and it made a horrible to play in last
Titan standing the second map that got
the most votes for the worst map was
complex which also got the same amount
of complaints for being close quarters
when in a Titan and some of the terrain
placement being random and almost
useless to be in the map the third and
final map for the top three worst maps
was exoplanet some people complained and
I personally agreed on the fact that
it's such a huge map in it being a
problem when being a pilot and not being
able to cross the map before getting
killed by Titan or sniped from another
pilot on the other side it's also hard
to gain speed to get to the other side
faster because all open terrain and you
cannot chain wall runs together but
there you guys have it these are the
three worst of maps from the community
on reddit in my opinion on titanfall 2
if you enjoyed hit the like button helps
me out and comment below what are your
three worst maps are in titanfall 2 and
if you want to see more be sure to
subscribe have a good day guys peace